hello and welcome this is model stream
number 007.2 it's the 18th of January
2023 we're back in our second session on
Pi mdp welcome back Connor thanks for
joining again and off to you for a
presentation that you will weave
together with some code examples and the
notebook that we'll use is in the video
description so thanks again Connor off
to you
great thank you Daniel it's great to be
back here again I think I've been here
maybe four or five times now so it's
always a pleasure to be with you all um
so yeah as Daniel said this is the
second
um model stream in a two-part Series
where we'll be discussing implementing
active inference with pi mdp
so um just like there's some background
that I'm assuming you either know from
your own research into active inference
and palm DPS in particular or because
you've watched the first part of the
series so
um I'll just say that to start with like
if you want background I would encourage
you to go watch the first part where we
talk about Pi mdp the motivation for the
package uh what you can do with it in
kind of sweeping terms and then today
we're actually going to go in and use it
to code up an active inference agent
performing a task like a reinforcement
learning style task
um that's very similar to Classic active
inference tests that you can find in the
literature
um yeah so as Daniel said I'm gonna step
through these slides I have pauses for
questions and stuff but we also have
pauses for code
um live coding or side by side coding so
I'll take a pause from the slides and
we'll go over to the
um a collab notebook the link is in the
description of the YouTube video and uh
and we'll kind of code up this agent
based on things that we discuss in the
slides
um it's not that I'll be actually
writing code I'll just be running cell
blocks
um and yeah so if if anyone who's
viewing
um wants to do it themselves you can
open the collab notebook actually let's
start by doing that
because
um so this should be the co-op notebook
that you get brought to when you
um click on the link and then and this
is one copy you need to have a Google
account to use this because Co-op is
linked to your Google Drive of your
Google account so if you're doing this
um on your own this is a shared link but
it's not
um you can't edit it you can't write to
it so what you have to do is go to file
up here then save a copy and drive and
then you'll get your own personal
private copy of the notebook and I'll do
that right now because I'll create a run
copy where we can like manipulate it all
together in real time
so I'll just call it run copy
um and I'll start by just installing
into this collab environment
uh Pi mdp so collab is kind of like
Jupiter notebooks it's an interactive
Cloud hosted notebook for running
different kinds of code but mainly
python code
um so while that's installing and I'll
run that as well
we can start with the slides
Okay so
um
so I'll just start with a quick review
from last time and again go back to the
video if you want to see the full
picture of what we discussed so the
generative models the kind of brains of
the agents that we'll be constructing
are these partially observed Markov
decision processes or Palm DPS
um they have various parameters and it's
kind of up to you how to parameterize
them but under active inference we
typically have these four main
components there's fifth and sixth
depending on how complicated of a model
you want to create but these components
kind of represents the agent's beliefs
about the world that it's operating in
so these are usually hand designed or at
least generally structured on a
case-by-case basis according to the
behavioral task that you're trying to
model so we have the a matrix or a array
which encodes the agent's beliefs about
how hidden states of the world that it's
doing inference about relate to the
observations that it gets you have the B
array which encodes uh beliefs about
transitions or beliefs about Dynamics so
how do hidden States relate to each
other over time
um you have the C vector or C array
which encodes agents prior preferences
for seeing certain sorts of Sensations
so this kind of plays the role of a
quasi-reward function and it has the
effect of biasing Agents action
selection such that it's more likely to
visit states of Affairs that it a priori
expects to see I.E goal directed
Behavior wants to achieve some goal and
then we have the D Vector which is kind
of a baseline prior about what is the
state of the world
um before I get any observations like
what do I believe the hidden State
distribution is and again I'm glossing
over this because I assume that you know
about things like categorical
distributions
um you know the we the all the details
of those these different arrays are
explained more in the first video
um
and just again to show the graphical
model we have the a array relating
hidden States in red to observations in
blue we have the B Matrix or B array
that relate on hidden states to
themselves over time so how does the
world change
and then we have policies Pi which are
uh sequences or collections of actions
that affect Transitions and thereby
change the state of the world
and then you have this critical
quasi-seudo value function to active
inference in Palm DPS active inference
in general which is the expected free
energy and the expected free energy is
the thing you try to minimize as you
optimize your beliefs about policies so
the best policies are those that
minimize expected free energy
and that has a bunch of interesting
terms that lend active inference all of
its interesting curious uh information
seeking behaviors and then this prior
over observations factors into the
computation of that expected free energy
so if you have a particular prior
preference to see some observations that
will affect
which policies get more or less expected
free energy and then you use that to
actually choose a policy
and then of course we have the D Vector
which parameterizes the initial uh
beliefs about his and states
so today
um we're going to actually dive in and
write out our own a b c's and D's for
particular
um a generative model we don't have to
worry about writing it out our own
functions that do inference and or do
planning all of that will be handled by
the abstractions provided by Prime DP
per tip particularly in the agent class
so the Aging class takes the components
of the generative model it gives you
this very kind of Black Box API that you
can just use to perform active inference
um this is a very in the last video we
talked about different levels of
abstraction this is like the top level
of abstraction in pi mdp where you're
just passing a generative model to an
agent and then kind of pressing go on
the agent
um having it interact with the task
environment so typically this is another
class like an environment class or a
task class and then you just kind of
string the two together in an action
perception Loop and uh and you get a
simulation of behavior under active
inference
and this is a a standard thing you'll
see in like open AI gym or other
reinforcement learning packages you'll
have usually like an environment class
and an agent class and they exchange
actions and observations in order so we
we designed the API of Pi mdp very much
uh inspired by that
um Okay so
before we start writing down the
generative model so that a b c and d
um I want to spend a little bit of time
exploring the idea of factorized State
spaces
and this is important because not only
the model we're working today it's
important to understand factorization in
both observations and hidden States
but for almost all the most interesting
Palm DP models you're going to want to
build it's going to be really crucial to
factorize your system in some way not
only because it becomes easier to reason
about and work with when things are
factorized but also it handles a lot of
computational explosions that happen if
you don't factorize your state space
[Music]
um
so it's not it's often useful to
categorically separate observations into
different modalities and hidden States
into different factors so what this
means is that when we get an observation
we're actually getting a collection of
different observations one coming from
each distinct sensory modality or
channel so similarly for hidden States
at any given time the hidden states are
described by a distinct set of different
features or what we call Hidden State
factors and so we refer to this as a
factorized representation because the
different modalities are independent of
each other
and the different hidden states are also
um independent of each other their
Dynamics are so they evolve in time
without ex affecting the other hidden
State factors so that's formally written
down as follows like the modalities
um are conditionally independent of each
other given the hidden States that's
what this factorization of the
likelihood looks like
um so you can think of the different
modalities as different sensory channels
like visual Vision audition
somatosensation and they provide their
own distinct type of information which
are then integrated together during
inference and factorizing the hidden
States is like the idea that any given
time the world can be described by
independent features like an object
being described by both its location and
space as well as its identity
um and factorizing the state's
representations of the model in this way
allows for a few different distinct
advantages one is computational
efficiency both in terms of memory and
um CPU
it simplifies the structure of the
generative model itself so it lends it a
bit of interpretability and transparency
so there's only certain sets of
variables that represent the agent's
beliefs about one feature of the
environment for instance and then
finally some would argue it has a degree
of neuronal or biological plausibility
and is consistent with the idea of
factorized on what others would call
Modular representations in the brain so
this part of this group of neuronal
populations deals with representing
where something is in space and this
group of neuronal populations deals with
representing the Identity or what the
thing is
um so that that's kind of the reason we
do this factorization
um so one of the most classic examples
of uh the the early examples we do in pi
MVP and this can be found on the uh
documentation and on the main page is
this a grid World example where the
agent is kind of
um
navigating in a 2d grid World space uh
then in the notebooks online we do like
a two byte of three by three grid wool
so there's nine total locations and in a
fully unfactorized or what we call an
enumerated State space representation
every location in Grid world has its own
um particular uh like Identity or state
so we just arbitrary can label them like
location zero all the way to location
eight and that that covers all nine
levels of grid World
um this is fine but it especially for a
small state space like a three by three
grid world but it leads to some it kind
of taxes our our memory and our uh our
interpretability a little bit because we
have to remember exactly how our nine
indices map to our uh the different
places in Grid world so like if I'm in
the middle of the grid I need to like
have some kind of lookup table to say
okay location four is uh
like zero or one comma one I.E the
middle location the grid in a factorized
representation
the grid could be represented as two
orthogonal or independent hidden State
factors one is something like the X
displacement or the horizontal
displacement which now just takes three
values like which column of grid world
are you in and then uh vertical
displacement or a y position which is
something like which row of grid will
dot am I in
and so now each hidden state is not a
single nine-dimensional Vector but it's
actually a combination or a pair of two
hidden State factors so two three
vectors instead of a single nine vector
and then a given hidden State itself is
picked out by a coincidence of these two
hidden State factors so if the X
position is one and the Y position is
two then it means I'm in
um
two are one comma two so like the middle
bottom of the of the grid world
and then once you do this so once we
have a factorized hidden state
representation it has implications for
the way we construct the generative
model so in a kind of simple generative
model you would just have one B array
that in the original uh grid World
example just is like nine possible
hidden States the nine possible
locations of where I just was that maps
to the nine possible subsequent hidden
States so the nine possible locations I
could be going to and then you'd have
that nine by nine Matrix conditioned on
the different actions so in the grid
World demo
the actions are typically local like
move up move left move down move right
um but once you factorize things you're
going to actually now have a collection
of B matrices and this is a consequence
of the factorization across the
transition models that we discussed a
few slides ago so you're going to have
one B Matrix or one set of B arrays for
the X displacement so how does the agent
move in the X Direction so these are
what each of these X
um these X displacement
um B matrices look like conditioned on
different actions so this is what it
looks like from moving left this is what
the B Matrix looks like for moving right
and this is what it looks like for stay
and then similarly you'll have another B
Matrix that encodes the agent's
abilities to move in the vertical
direction or Y displacement and
similarly they actually look identical
um because the the world is is like
rotation and translation invariant
and you'll have a another smaller B
array just for y movement this is a very
simple example we're not going to
actually do this in code because it's
kind of trivial but it's just an example
of how instead of having a location
fully enumerated representation you can
split that up into basically a y-axis
and an x-axis
so now we're gonna We're Not Gonna
simulate an active inference agent but
we're just gonna play around with these
data structures to get you used to the
idea of factorized representations and
how that manifests in the code so now
we'll go over to collab
so if you've been running this on your
own this should all be
downloaded
um so you've installed in infra actively
dashed Pine DP that's the whole name of
the package
that's now in your environment and then
you should also run this some basic
Imports like numpy and Pi mdp which is
now in the environment
mm-hmm okay and so the basic variables
that you'll see
are things like
the yes so there's a few variables that
are almost always part of any pine DP
workflow and this is very much mirrored
on how it's done in SPM in the Dem
toolbox so typically you'll have a list
that specifies the dimensionalities or
the number of different levels of each
hidden State Factor so for our three our
three by three grid world nine possible
States we have one X Factor of three
levels and one y factor of three levels
and then the length of that list tells
us the total number of hidden State
factors so in this case we have two
hidden State factors and then similarly
we have uh hidden you have hidden states
are factorized and then similarly you
factorize your control States so for
every hidden State Factor there's also
going to be a control State factor and
the fact that these are also
three-dimensional each just basically
means that the agent has three possible
actions in the x-axis and three possible
actions in the y-axis and then the
number of control factors is also gonna
be two in that case
and so we have some nice utility
functions that can quickly build a b
array given the the two things that are
necessary uh the num States and num
controls variables so you just do
uh initialize empty B
some states and number controls
and then you'll have
a b Matrix
that has you know the correct shapes and
stuff
so three rows three columns and three
possible actions for the X Direction and
similarly for the Y Direction so this is
just basic setting up your variables
um
and often we'll have these solution
cells that are hidden underneath each
little quasi exercise so that's
something you can do as well
okay and so that's just and that's just
initializing an empty array right so we
don't actually know what's uh
what those contingencies are that we saw
in the in the slides but if we want to
populate this thing
so this is what each
Factor specific B array looks like then
we have to go into these matrices and
actually fill out the rows columns and
third order slices with numbers so for
instance this Loop where we Loop over
factors and we fill out the different
entries of the B array what this will do
is just encode those local actions like
move left move right for The X Factor
and then move up move down for the Y
factor and so once you've run that code
you basically filled out all the numbers
in that that Big Empty B array that you
started and then you can use things like
the plot likelihood function to to plot
these likelihood distributions action
conditioned likelihood distributions as
matrices so this is move uh left for
instance if we're in the x hidden State
factor and if we change this to a one
we've changed the action index then this
is
move right and then similarly if we
change this this is move
down if we're doing action one here
um oh and just uh so darker colors
whether it's grayscale or red or
whatever
almost unanimously in Prime DP the
darker colors represent more probability
so that's just for
um
so instead of having to display numbers
we'll just show darker numbers
okay so now let's go back to the slides
and talk about the a arrays
so in in our unfactorized fully
enumerated grid World example and again
I'll refer you to the documentation of
primevp if if uh if you want to like
play around with that example the hidden
State factors which are just these nine
kind of arbitrarily labeled locations
map to an observation modality which is
like the agent's sensation of its own
position kind of appropriate receptive
GPS modality you could think of it as
like they're sensing where they are at
any given time and so um there are
various ways you could uh encode that
but let's just pretend that they have a
very high fidelity GPS so they're
getting precise GPS readouts of where
they are at any given time so in in a
fully enumerated world that a matrix
that likelihood modality would look like
this
when we start factorizing things so
splitting up the hidden State factors
into an X Factor and a y factor that
choice not only manifests in the B
arrays but it also manifests in the
structure of the areas and I think this
is one of the most key things to
understand because when it comes to
coding these things up yourself
understand how these arrays are
structured is really important to
getting things working
um
like successfully
so it's basically getting used to
multi-dimensional indexing so
the briefly uh in summary when you have
multiple hidden State factors that
manifests as extra lagging Dimensions or
extra higher order dimensions in your um
in your a array so it's not really an a
matrix anymore it's an a tensor so that
means if you have two hidden State
factors the number of lagging Dimensions
I.E excluding rows that's what I mean
when I say lagging Dimensions will be
two so you have columns and slices in
addition to rows so this is really
important to understand when either
using SPM or pi mdp to do pom DP based
active inference and another way of
saying this is for each additional
random variable that we're conditioning
our observations on we have an
additional lagging dimension in our
array so this is the same Principle as
with the B matrices because we condition
the next state both on the past State
and the past action that's why the B
arrays are also tensors so we have two
extra dimensions in the B array one for
each conditioning variable past State
and past action so now in the in the X
and Y factorized grid world we have two
lagging Dimensions where the first
lagging Dimension the columns in blue
index a particular X location and the
second lagging Dimension the slices if
you will index a particular Y location
so now what I'm going to do
is unwrap these slices of the
multi-dimensional a matrix
um
and so you can see that each slice of
the a matrix so that each purple indexed
third order slice corresponds to
conditioning on a particular setting of
Y so a particular conditional
distribution over observations for the
three settings of X for a fixed value of
y so each slice is exactly this
conditional distribution
where we're looking at the conditional
distributions over observations for each
setting of X so those are the The
Columns indexed by the blue numbers at
the bottom
but we're fixing to one value of y so
that's the conditional distribution over
observations 0 1 and 2 so being in the
top row given that we're in the first
the first row y equals zero for the
three possible settings of X and then we
move down to this next set of
observations
and uh the next slice of Y and it looks
like that and then finally like that
so this is the case where our GPS is uh
noiseless and High Fidelity right that's
why we have like hyper Dark Cells and
then everything else is white is because
the agent believes that its observations
are High Fidelity
um signals of the actual hidden State
namely the X comma Y location
so then when we Pat these back together
we see how this full a matrix or set of
conditional distributions will be
represented by a nine by three by three
tensor where again each lagging
Dimension exists to encode the
conditional dependencies between that
particular hidden State Factor indexed
by the lagging Dimension and the
observations for this modality so when I
index into the ith column and the jth
slice of this a matrix or a tensor I'm
basically slicing out a particular
conditional distribution over
observations where I'm deciding what
settings
of the conditional distributions or the
conditional very random variables I'm
interested in
um
okay so yeah that's uh that's a kind of
critical concept and to just uh make it
more
um tangible and clear
and I mean to be clear this isn't the
only way to encode conditional
dependencies in categorical
distributions but it's just the way that
was originally uh used in SPM to encode
these dependencies and then we just
borrowed that convention when building a
primevp and it's pretty useful because
it makes generating things like
conditional expectations pretty
straightforward
um using like a linear algebra
operations like
higher order dot products and stuff like
that so we have this
kind of unwrapped representation of the
array here and we can use this to
uh to refer back to when we're building
our array so
um one thing I didn't mention that is
also important is that in the same way
we can factorize hidden States we can
factorize modalities so we'll have we'll
talk about that in a second but just for
now let's assume we have one single GPS
sensing modality of nine possible levels
of where I am in Grid world so it's just
a list of one number nine
and then the number of modalities will
trivially be one the length of that list
and then we can use similarly this utils
initialize empty a array which takes the
number of observation modalities their
dimensions and the number of hidden
States
and then it creates
um the a array with the proper
dimensions and everything
so I've also created this combined list
called a location dims which is a
combination of the number of observation
modality dimensions and the number of
hidden State Factor Dimensions so that's
as we said going to be 933
and so then we can populate our first
the entry of our first modality in the a
matrix which is trivially here the only
modality with a matrix of zeros
this is actually what's happening under
the hood in this thing so we don't need
to do it here
but then if we just run that then we'll
see that the shape of a0 is the same as
a location divs
um okay so that's just initializing it
so we now have one a array that has one
modality whose shape is nine by three by
three and then we just go and fill it
out like we saw up here so I'm filling
it out under the assumption of this
noiseless high high quality GPS sensor
so you can see when I'm indexing into
the lagging Dimension here the the Y
Dimension which is the third dimension
of the tensor I'm saying for this
particular value of y which is when Y is
zero
um we're in the first row of grid world
then the conditional distribution over
the three settings of the GPS given all
the settings of X is just an identity
Matrix so I'm just coding that that
little chunk right there and then we can
go through each of the slices
iteratively and do that
um so yeah one of the things I think is
a disadvantage currently of both Prime
DP and the SPM is I think we need better
ways to make people not have to do these
multi-dimensional indexing operations to
encode a particular conditional
independency structure and I thought of
ways to do that but it's actually pretty
hard to do that in a generic flexible
way where people can just come to the
table with their own semantics and then
all this gets done for them so for now
you still have to kind of do this by
hand or write some algorithmic way to do
it that's specific to your task
but uh but yeah that's just something to
mention is like it would it's not ideal
that we have users doing this but I at
the moment I can't really think of a
better way to do it
um
and then once we've encoded that we can
look at our little conditional
distributions given different settings
of why you know and that's just one
choice we could also condition on X and
look at for all settings of Y
x equals zero
like you can slice this up however you
want right
um that's just a a visualization choice
and these are our three
collections of conditional distributions
one for each setting of Y
okay
um
you know let's go back to the slides
yes so one thing I didn't mention uh or
I said I would mention is we we just had
a a single observation modality but just
as for hidden States we can factorize
um and we don't have to fully enumerate
our observation space so we could
separate the grid GPS observations into
an X and A Y GPS so now you're observing
a pair of different observations at any
given time One X observation and one y
so just like we had a separate B array
for each hidden State Factor similarly
we now have a separate a array for each
observation modality so we would
populate one big a object array with
these different modality specific Aras
so in this case if we had X observations
and Y observations we would have two a
sub arrays each one would have size
three by three by three because three
observations and then for the two
possible states of the Hidden State
factors
so yeah that wraps up the the um slides
I had on
multi-factor multi modality factorized
representations and how that affects A
and B arrays so uh before we move on to
the contextual multi-arm Bandit um let's
open it up for questions or comments if
anything was unclear and someone wants
to contribute their own way of
explaining something I'm happy to talk
about that now
awesome Jacob then Adam and Carl if
you'd like
yeah uh thanks a lot for the great uh
overview I had a question on uh
initializing the B Matrix so in this
case we uh initialized it with the
simplest policy just all of the
available actions the agent has is there
um
would there be any particular use case
in the grid World example where we would
want to initialize it with a sequence
of uh of policies and is that needed if
we want to do planning of different
temporal depth
So when you say sequence of policies can
you give me like an example
like instead of in instead of
um conditioning uh conditioning
it on just move up viewed conditioning
on move up and down
fixed sequences of of actions
right right that's interesting okay so
that's so yeah typically when we are
building these transition likelihoods
this is more of a consequence of the
fact that it's a palm
a p-o-m-dp with an emphasis on the m so
it's markovian so if you want to
encode something like
what is the predicted next hidden State
given
I did move up and move down in the last
two time steps if I'm understanding
correctly you're like saying can
condition my B Matrix my next hidden
State on a sequence of two possible uh
past actions then we're breaking the
Markov property of the Dynamics because
we're saying the next thing says not
just depends on what I did at the last
time step in the end the state but it
depends on also what I did two time
steps ago so now you have a higher order
temporal dependence like a semi-markov
model or uh yeah really just not a
markup model but a higher order model
and that's not something that's
currently supported in pi mdp the
natural way you get around that is by
building a hierarchical model
um so at at each individual
um level of the hierarchy you have a pom
DP but then when you look at a single
layer like the bottom layer of this
hierarchical model
it is a semi-markov model or
non-markovian if you take into account
what all the other layers are doing
um but but that's not uh currently
supported at the level of a single
Markov model like you can't build a b
Matrix that's dependent on more than
what happened at the last time step it
always has to you yeah you can't have
like an extra lagging Dimension that
encodes also what were they doing two
time steps ago
um
that so that's one interpretation of
when you say policy like up down I think
of two actions uh that happen in in
locks in sequence
um but maybe another thing and correct
me if I'm uh reading too deeply into
your question another thing would be can
I have actions in a different control
State Factor affect the Dynamics of the
of a particular hidden State Factor so
say I had one hidden State factor which
is move up
uh and another uh I said one factor
which is y displacement another Factor
that's X displacement can I have the
Dynamics of the Y Factor not just depend
on my y action but also on my X action
um so that's the idea of
basically breaking
this uh conditional sorry this
Independence property
where is it here
I don't know let me find it here
so if you
you allowed the lower right shows that
the dynamic the state of one factor over
time only depends on the state of of
that factor at the previous time step
but if you said I could also can make
this conditionally dependent
on not just factor F but say Factor
um I or Q
at T minus one
this is something that's also not
currently supported but I think is an
interesting idea which is you would
actually have interactions between maybe
pairs of hidden State factors
in in Hidden State space this actually
can be accommodated under uh Pine DP
like like mathematically I haven't built
in the functionality to do it but I
think there's nothing that stops you in
principle from doing this so this would
be as if I can have actions from
different control factors all
influencing the next state of one hidden
State Factor
um and that is something that will
probably make the message passing
a little bit more not maybe not more
complicated but maybe there's
convergence properties wouldn't be as
guaranteed I don't know what it looks
because you're introducing weird Loops
in your your graph but um in the factor
graph that represents the generative
model but uh that's something in theory
could be uh entertained but I I don't
know if that's actually what you had in
mind maybe you had more in mind of
breaking the Markov property when you
say
yeah it was
um thank you for the answer it was more
of a clarification also on the
mathematical notation uh because uh
Pi uh it's interpreted as policy which I
guess can be both individual actions and
sequences of actions
um yeah so just wanted to clarify that
yeah that's a good point so when I said
Pi up here
I meant
um
I meant yeah so
in in if Paul if Pi was a sequence of
actions that any any given time the B
Matrix that you're indexing out is
conditioned on the action that's
entailed by the policy at that
particular time but the B Matrix will
never be entailed on like what's going
on in the full policy but just by okay
at time t i take out this slice of the B
Matrix because at time T this is the
action entailed by this policy of
sequence length H or something but uh
yeah that's a good point so in the in in
a trivial case policy length is one and
there's just one action that's
uh the policy is just an action that
comes down to slice out the b Matrix
thanks Jacob Adam anything you like to
add go for it yeah a couple follow-ups
uh thank you for this very clear
presentation Connor so first um just to
follow on what Yakov just asked it seems
like another potential way if you wanted
to do this sort of two-time Step uh
model would be to actually condenser or
kind of permute those two time steps
into a single uh variable the same way
that you you know could condense the row
and column into a single nine Dimension
you know nine nine row vector or you can
break it down into two could you
similarly break down the last two moves
and sort of combine them into a
permutation of all possibilities of the
last two moves and have those be the
hidden States
yeah uh you could do that as well I
don't I haven't seen that actually done
in practice the only thing is you'd have
to actually have to somehow change the
there
[Music]
um
you have to change the the scheduling I
guess of the message passing in the
action to accommodate the fact that
before I determine what my last hidden
state was I need to like wait two time
steps so I can get not only the proximal
action I did but also have this memory
of the action two time steps ago
um yeah I was imagining that you'd have
some special special case for the first
move where it's like undefined and then
the last move then after that you'd have
the last two moves a separate Matrix for
those or something yeah like a moving
window kind of so it's always yeah
remembering the last yeah I I could see
that working
um I think like the active like kind of
the canonical active inference
answer to that is instead of having to
kind of manufacture this special way of
represent of basically baking memory
into a markovian system the classical
way to handle that is just to build a
hierarchical model because the
hierarchical model handles that memory
um easily by just having
like nested markovian processes where if
you if you were to look at a single
process it looks like it has memory but
that's just because it's priors for its
own markovian process are evolving as a
function of another Palm DP that's
operating at a slower time scale
um so like I I could imagine doing that
exact exact thing that you're talking
about if you had a
low-level Palm DP that was moving twice
as fast as the top level Palm DP and so
basically with the top level Palm DP is
doing is setting an initial prior over
one action that then allows the slow
level Palm DP to condition whatever it
does next on the behave on like a belief
that whatever I do next I know that I
just took
um this action two time steps ago but
you don't actually have to hand craft
that it's just by building a one Palm DP
like within another Palm DP
um but I don't see that there's anything
in principle going against what you're
describing as well
it's just yeah I like your approach a
lot better
yeah this is this is um I mean
essentially what I learned from from
working with Carl was that like any time
you're trying to imbue a system with
more complex non-markovian Memory full
Dynamics or higher order dependencies
that's when you it's the natural move is
to go to a hierarchical model
um because it kind of handles it all
naturally
[Music]
so my next question is
um about the uh what you were sort of
tweaking in that formula just a couple
minutes ago where you were suggesting
the possibility that there could be
feedback loops you know between the
hidden States in theory but but as
currently implemented if I understood
correctly that's not the case the state
of us of one of the Hidden variables or
so in the state of one of the Hidden
States depends only on
the previous dates of that the previous
state of that hidden State as currently
yeah but I want to make yeah a hidden
Factor what I want to make sure I I
understand is that is that also
something about
the markovian Assumption or is that just
sort of an implementation or design
decision
completely separate from the markup
yeah that's that's a good question
that's separate from the Markov
um that's separate from the markovian
Assumption so that's something having to
do with kind of just how the graph that
represents the generative model which
you could think of as like a Bayesian
graph like a bunch of nodes
that uh affects a layer of observations
so you say a bunch of hidden State nodes
that all uh
all have all the observation nodes
conditionally depend on the state of all
the hidden State Factor nodes by
constructing it this way you basically
have a graph that it's very easy to do
inference on that has like stationary
fixed points so the inference does not
depend on like initial conditions of the
posteriors and things like that so um
this is like a kind of a bar the way the
generic model is set up right now is
like a bipartite graph that resembles a
classic
um uh model for machine learning called
like a restricted boltzmann machine so
this is where all the hidden States
can all affect one uh observation
modality but there's no interactions
between the observation layers so
there's no lines going between
observations within one modality and
there's also no lines going between
hitting State factors so that's that's
kind of what we're what one of the
advantages of this assumption is is when
you have the hidden State factors be
only dependent on their own past State
and their own past action within that
control Factor then you're not
introducing these Loops in the graph
that make inference a little bit harder
so you'll see this structure in when
people are using like restricted
Baltimore machines or other or even deep
neural networks it's very hard to get a
fixed Point solutions for like the
posteriors when you're when you have
interactions between nodes in a single
layer so it's not quite the same thing
as as
um it's yeah it's just not the same
thing as a the Markov property has more
having to do with generating an acyclic
graph so you can do a fast efficient and
fixed Point inference on it I mean that
that's my general answer to that because
if you look actually draw out the factor
graph for these things it looks
like that but there might be another
reason this is done that I'm actually
not aware of
um maybe that's something that Carl uh
would know
but or or someone else
if you want to add anything Carl
otherwise
and then after this we'll head into the
script go for it Carl thank you
um yeah I think everything that needs to
be said has already been said very very
clearly and very usefully uh but yes
Connor's absolutely right
um so I look at this
um in terms of the overall architecture
of the graphical model you bring to the
table and you know it can only have a
number of different attributes you know
how deep is it how many levels does it
have
um we're not in this presentation
talking about uh deep uh
um mdp or generative models based upon
um
um hierarchically composed uh Markov
decision uh processes uh but we you know
generally you would think of any one
level in the context of the level above
and the level below and that lends this
attribute of depth to Any Given
generative model but probably more
important certainly from the point of
view of the current discussion is the
Barrette and the barrette's basically
the number of uh
independent actors in physics this is
simply known as the field approximation
it's you know it's just the
factorization of a joint distribution in
this instance
um
what we're aiming for is an approximate
posterior distribution but it's a
factorization into conditionally
independent factors that incidentally
also induces certain Markov blankets and
resolves a lot of the message passing
and uh means sort of variational
iterations are more robust but
um from the point of view of your why do
you do that well you do that because to
maximize the marginal likelihood of the
evidence for your generative model you
have to carve the nature out there at
its joints in the right kind of way so
if the world you're trying to navigate
or exchange with or explain
um does have the this factorization is
conditional independencies it is carved
in this way then your model has to
comply in order to have the maximum
evidence
um so when learning that particular
factorization or that structure you
would normally apply a process of basic
model selection or structure loan to get
the number of factors right so and that
is getting the right kind of mean
approximation apt for this world and and
these data and the right factorization
will simply minimize variational free
energy and therefore minimize the
computational complexity and also the uh
the computational complexity expressed
in terms of thermodynamics for example
so it's a really important sort of thing
and there's a couple of the little um
endorsement comments
um you know
conditioning any one
um state with any one factor on States
and other factors destroys that that
particular factorization so you don't
have to worry about introducing loops
and things all you all you're doing is
saying that particular factorization has
gone away you've coarse grained and you
now have to lump together all the
elements of one factor and the other
factor into one bigger factor and now
you've got a couple more coarse grain
factorization and more
mathematically complex model because you
haven't done as many carvings uh in you
know tourism you know to Leverage The
conditional independencies that you
um you're trying to model and the first
question about the policy is that that
was an interesting one I suspect it may
be an artifact of um the way that we
condition everything on I without sort
of forwarding people I is actually quite
a complicated variable
um first of all it's basically you're an
index or a a name for quite a
complicated combination of things so not
only is it a sequence of
um actions
um upon which you condition each
individual transition at any point in
time over time so it's a sequence of
actions so an answer to Jacob's question
um you know the whole point of the
expeditary energy is exploring lots and
lots of different sequences as you run
out into the future
um
but also
um induced by the factorization as Conor
was saying
um the that pie actually has to now
entail a action for every factor of a
fixed combination so if you change the
the combination of actions for two
factors you now have a different policy
even at one time step even for one step
ahead so the notion of a policy as a
combination of actions uh is still in
play when you have a factorized mean
field approximation of the Hidden States
so if you know it's a subtle Point
usually would resolve it by actually
explicitly writing down usually the
using the variable U the thing that
you're conditioning the state
transitions on and then you
um comes from a family of combinations
of views over factors and over time
um so you can have deep and shallow
policies but even you've got very
shallow policies one step ahead and one
look ahead apologize there's still a
subset of combinations of actions you
know so it could be that you can either
only move up or or down sorry up or to
the left but you can't move diagonally
for example yeah and so and that will be
placed um in terms of priors over Pi
namely combinations of of actions
oh so one final just for for Adam's
benefit that notion of um
putting semi-markovian Dynamics and I'm
getting kind of absolutely right that
the other the way that
um as a physicist the way you do that is
by appealing to the depth of the
hierarchical model which always entails
time and that's that's an absolutely
crucial observation there's no point in
adding depth to a generative model
unless you are mindful it is introducing
a separation of temporal time scales and
I think you know that's a profound
this sort of a structural insight into
the nature of genital models and has all
sorts of implications
um but then it you know just speaking to
this notion of sort of having
combinations of little histories or
little caches of Legacy State
um as if you like a superstead
um strictly speaking that is exactly
what is done effectively in continuous
text-based models with common filters so
you you actually have now two kinds of
random variables the position and the
velocity so you you've now got a sort of
dual representation and if you
generalize that you get a generalized
points of motion so you know
and technically
um when you're doing variational message
passing you now use something called a
chef face free energy as opposed to
which is a variant of variational free
energy
um however when you move to discrete
States there's generalized coordinates
now actually are replaced just by having
um states that unfold in time over the
um under the public transition Matrix so
that you you shouldn't in principle ever
need to do that but you can now regard
if you like the little local history the
little little packet or trajectory or
orbit
the path that you're taking at this
point at this Temple scale
um as sufficiently discretized and cause
brain with the different probability
transition matrices and then at the
slower time scale then it's a succession
of initial States that's normally how we
would think about that but it's a it's
an interesting
game to think about how what kinds of
structures in these dispute States based
models Echo the equivalent movements one
has to make in continuous State space
modeling and uh and thinking here
particularly generalized filtering and
Bayesian smoothing and Bayesian
filtering and the line
yeah thank you that's a really it's
really nice to have uh those
afterthought like because that clarifies
I think and justifies a lot of the
preceding slides or what what Carl just
said
um
yeah that's that's a good I I so you can
kind of map the depth of the hierarchy
think of the depth of the hierarchy as a
discretization of what is smoothly
handled with generalized filtering and
generalized coordinates of motion
um so States evolving at this Pawn DP
are kind of like a quasi-velocity
variable
uh because they are evolving slower than
the position variable which is like the
low level quick faster clock uh Palm DP
one one just tiny footnote there is it
relates to the continuous and
differentiable free energy landscape and
the discretization that is required on
Modern digital Hardware around sampling
and the discretization problem on a
continuous but hidden
function
and the approaches that we have to take
to discretize the continuous nature of
time especially
absolutely
[Music]
okay
um
so
I think we should proceed to the um the
multi-on Bandit
um okay so now having discussed these
kind of factorized representations we're
in a position to build our multi-factor
generative model for what I'm calling a
contextual two-armed Bandit or
contextual multi-arm Bandit this is
coming from the um you know
reinforcement learning literature This
this term contextual but
uh it's based directly on a kind of
gambling task that was introduced in
Ryan Smith Christopher white Carl's
friston's step-by-step tutorial on
active inference so you basically have a
multi-arm bandit two-armed Bandit but
you have to first find a clue or uh
forage information to figure out which
of the two slot machines or arms of the
Bandit is more favorable and this is
echoed as well in the original teammates
example where you have a rat that has to
choose between two arms one is more
rewarding than the other but you don't
know which one is rewarding so you have
to visit a informative Q State first
that tells you the left one is rewarding
right now or the right one is rewarding
so this I'm just kind of gathering all
these things into the term contextual
Bandit because that's kind of the
analogous uh term for this problem that
you'll find in like reinforcement
learning world
um okay
so in the multi-arm Bandit or two on
Bandit task an agent has to play choose
to play one of two slot machines and
they can only play one at a time so one
of the slot machines gives more reward
than the other but the agent doesn't
know which is the better one so at any
given time the agent can choose to play
the left or the right machine that's
what we'll call them or can choose to
ask for a hint
and if it chooses to ask for a hint
instead of playing the machine it
receives information about which of the
two slot machines is better so this sets
up this already sets up the basic
dilemma of tasks like this the so-called
explore exploit dilemma so you first
Forge for information that will
ultimately lead to getting more reward
or do you gamble immediately in order to
get rewards sooner but at the risk of
not having enough information to know
which uh slot machine I should actually
play so to encode this task structure
into a generative model for a palm DP we
equip the agent with three observation
modalities first we have this hint
modality which is the sensory channel
the agent uses to perceive the hint so
just what is the state of the hint then
there's a reward modality which tells
the agent whether it won or lost at the
selected machine and then finally
there's a choice modality which is just
the agent's proprioceptive observation
of its own choice this is equivalent to
the GPS modality that we were working
with in Grid world
and in terms of hidden State factors we
first have a context factor which is a
binary variable encoding Which slot
machine is the more rewarding one either
the left machine is better or the right
machine is better so those are the names
of the two context variables you could
just arbitrary enable in my context a
context b or something like that and
then we have a choice hidden State
factor which is simply encoding the
choice state that the agent currently
occupies
um and finally as Carl was just
explaining for each hidden State Factor
you also have a control Factor so we'll
have a context control factor which as
we'll see is Trivial since the agent
can't control the context in in this
particular
um simulation and a choice control
factor which is the control factor that
allows the agent to model its own
actions or choices so even for a shallow
policy Horizon as Carl was explaining
a policy will still be comprised of two
actions so it'll be there will be a
context action and a choice action but
as we'll see the context action will
always be to do nothing or basically to
not be able to interfere in the Dynamics
of the context Wednesday factors so
basically action selection comes down to
just choosing the state of the choice
control Factor
on that you Choice variable so now we're
going to look at the different levels of
the Hidden State factors
so as we said the context one is a
binary
um or you could think of it as like a
Bernoulli variable so it's either left
bed or right better it's a distribution
over these two states of the context
and this is just the unchanging state of
the world for a particular trial either
left machine has a better payoff
probability or the right one does
and then the choice hidden State Factor
has four levels which correspond to the
four possible Choice states that the
agent can be in so this can either be
the neutral starting location
on the hint state which is the location
they they occupy when they're acquiring
the hint
um and or they can be playing the left
machine or they can be playing the right
machine and so now for the control State
factors
the control State factor for the context
only has one level you can call it do
nothing or it's just a trivial
one-dimensional variable and the agent
will always take this action with 100
probability
so in other words the agent um has no
control over the state of the context
and then the choice control state has
four levels corresponding to the
decision to change
um the S Choice the hidden State factor
for the choice state in one of four
different ways either it can move to the
start location it can move to the hint
location it can play the left machine or
it can play the right machine so what
choice State the agent is in is kind of
obviously under the agent's control
which is encoded by the fact that this
u-choice variable has four levels
so optimizing a posterior distribution
over this Choice uh control State Factor
that's that's what action selection and
planning boils down to is basically
choosing what level of you Choice I'm
we're inferring what uh the distribution
over you choices and then sampling or
taking the ARG Max of that distribution
to actually make an action
okay so now let's review the observation
modalities and their different levels
the first modality is the hint modality
which can either give the outcomes of
null like I'm not at the hint state so
I'm getting no sensory information from
that channel a left is better hint hint
left or right is better hint and they're
just named that because you will see in
the a matrix how seeing that observation
relates to seeing the um two to the the
state of the context
um we have the null observation because
as I said if the agent isn't in the
choice state of getting a Hint it still
needs to receive some information from
that modality so that's why we often
have in both the SPM and the pine BP
implementations we have this null
observation that just encodes an
observation that has uh has no
information about hidden States within
uh some particular Factor
and then we have a reward modality which
similarly has a null observation for
when the agent isn't playing either slot
machine and then two possible reward
observations either a loss or a reward
but this is a a choice that can um
depends on what you're trying to do you
could also make a reward have like 10
different reward levels that have
different like magnitudes of rewards
it's just a choice to
call these like loss and reward one the
point being that one is preferred
relative to the other
and then finally we have the choice
modality which just allows the agent to
unambiguously infer what choice State
it's in so it just allows it to infer
what it's doing and this is important
because remember in active inference
everything has to be inferred everything
is about is in the game of minimizing
free energy and
um coming up with uh posteriors
approximate beliefs about the state of
the world including your own choice
state so that's why we often equip
agents with a proprioceptive sense of
where where I am like a GPS
um
yeah okay and and so that that's the
three observation manage we've done the
hidden States and the controls so now
we're in a position to start building
the a arrays for this agent's generative
model so for each modality specific a
array we're going to have as many rows
as there are levels of that modality and
then two columns and four slices and so
why is it two columns four slices
because each column corresponds to a
setting of the context hit and state
factor and each third order slice
corresponds to a setting of The Choice
State hidden State factor and these
lagging
dimensions of two columns four slices
will be the same for every single a
matrix not not the values in them but
that shape so the only thing that will
change across modalities the a uh
modality specific a arrays is the number
of rows which is the number of
observation levels so for the hint
modality each slice of this a matrix
tells us the mapping between the two
possible context States and the
observations in the hint modality for a
fixed Choice state that the agent could
be in so for instance if the agent is in
the start Choice State what we're seeing
now regardless of whether the left or
the right mission is better the agent
will always get the null observation
which has zero information about the
state of the context as you can see
because given
an observation of the null observation
in the hint modality you have no idea
whether the left is better or the right
is better however if the agent is in the
visit a hint state or acquire a hint
State then the mapping between the
contact State and the two hint
observations will be informative and why
I I say informative I just mean that the
columns of this Matrix will uh be
independent from each other and they
will be low entropy so another way
that's saying that is that there'll be
low entropy in the observation
conditioned rows of the Matrix so uh
briefly what we're seeing here where
grayscale darker colors means more
probability
if the slot less machine is better
that's the context then the agent is
more likely to see the hint left
observation and if the right machine is
better they're more likely to see the
the hint right observation so this slice
of the a matrix is what gives those
observation levels their their meaning
the the very region they're called Hit
left and hit right is just because of
the the kind of diagonal structure in
this slice of the Matrix and then
finally for the other states
um if I'm playing the left or the right
machine I'm never getting any
informative observations from this
modality
[Music]
um okay and then we move on to the
reward modality so again two columns and
four slices like for all the arrays but
now we're looking at the mapping between
the two context and the reward
observation levels so no loss reward for
each possible Choice State the agent can
be in so as we can see if the agent is
in starting location or getting the hint
they're not getting uh any reward
observation they get the trivial
meaningless null observation however if
the agent is playing the left or the
right machine
though there's a probabilistic mapping
between the context the left machine or
the right machine being better
and and uh the expected rewards so if
the context is left is better then the
agent is more likely to see the reward
if and only if they're playing the left
machine
uh likewise if they're playing the right
machine this Matrix
uh is the same so if you're paying right
then you're more likely to see reward so
this is this sub Matrix within this big
a tensor is what determines the payoff
structure of the task
um or the agent's beliefs about that
payoff structure I should say because
this is the area it's not the actual
rules of the game so now we're finally
up to the choice modality which again is
just their observation of Their Own
Choice state which you can see only
depends on the state of the choice
that they're making it doesn't depend on
the context so it just means that
they'll always unambiguously infer uh
whether they're playing the right
machine or they're in the start state or
whatnot so this is just an example of
going through those slices and really
seeing how that looks so now we can code
this up in collab and again we won't be
doing it by hand we'll just be
um we'll just be running some predefined
code so one useful thing to do often
with control factors and observation
modalities is get some semantic labels
like create a list of strings for
instance so the context names will have
these two states left better right
better choice names will have these four
possible States and then we can
automatically create these lists of
Dimensions that are needed to create
your A and B matrices just by looking at
things like the length of this list of
strings or the length of this list of
choice names so if you run this
then we'll have our num States
variable which will be
2 4 2 possible contexts and four
possible Choice States and then you'll
have num OBS which will be yeah three
possible hints three possible rewards
and four
proprioceptive location or Choice State
observations and then we can use this
function to initialize our empty a
matrix
and in the next few chunks of code
basically just fill out these a matrices
like we saw in the slides
um so one thing we'll do is we will have
two parameters and this is again
arbitrary you can choose to do this
however you want we'll parameterize the
a matrix with a probability of hint or a
hint accuracy which will effectively
just fill out that slice of the hint
modality a array that corresponds to how
accurately the hint
um signal
uh indicates the context or or lends
evidence to the context so if the hint
is 100 is 1.0 P hint is 1.0 it means
whenever they visit the hint State they
immediately know okay the left arm is
better
um but this doesn't have to be 100 right
the hint itself could have some noise or
uncertainty associated with it so we'll
parametrize that just with this
probability
um so this is
the probability of the two hint types or
the two game States and you see the null
has zero probability and then hint left
has more probably when the context is
left indicated by the column and then
hint right has more probably when the
context is right
and then we'll just go through and fill
out this Choice
um stuff oh you the reward modality will
have a similar thing a p reward so this
will determine the payoff structure of
both banded arms so if P reward is high
it means if the context is left is
better and you're playing the left slot
machine you'll have an 80 chance of
getting the reward
and this thing itself can be not changed
to determine basically how how rewarding
the bandits are
um
so this is the payoff structure uh if
you're playing the left arm the payoff
structure for the two contexts and
there's an inverseness that I didn't
discuss so if I'm playing the left arm
but the right arm is better
then I'm also more likely symmetrically
to get punishment or negative reward
with the same probability that I would
get positive reward if I was playing the
right on so just that that's also a
choice but just to make this a single
parameter that's how we we did it here
and then finally the choice observation
model is just filling out that GPS uh
High Fidelity GPS sensor
and that's pretty um
you know if you slice it along the
any context hidden State Factor since it
doesn't depend in context this could be
a zero or a one
then we'll get an identity mapping which
just allows them to infer their choice
state
and then we wrap this all into one
function so we just have two parameters
P hint P reward and then we can see once
we start doing simulations how
manipulating those things messes with
their behavior
so now we'll move on to the B arrays
um oh yeah so let me go here and talk
through some slides this will be quick
the bras are pretty simple so we're
gonna mess with this later but we're
gonna start by saying that
the context hidden State factor is
stationary over time so they can't
change that end State factor and even in
the absence of their ability to
intervene it it uh it stays in the same
state over time so we parametrize this
with like a p change probability that
just fills out the diagonal of this
um kind of trivial transition Matrix
with 100 probability but later on we can
mess with that parameter and decrease it
so they believe that the context can
actually change with some stochasticity
over time
um but for now we just assume they don't
believe the context changes
and uh and then this is their ability to
so unlike grid world where you have
local actions they can only move up down
left right here they can move from any
other state to any other state so this
is like a signature thing if you want a
controllable
um hidden State space so the agent can
go anywhere from any other place that
will manifest as these dark bands in
your in your B Matrix or bands of 100
probability so this is another way of
saying that the transition graph is
fully connected that you can get
anywhere from anywhere
um but that's also not sure like we
could have made it such that they once
they leave the start State they can't
return there so that would correspond to
having
um the absence of one of these uh uh
like basically the start state is a
source but it can't also be a a sink or
if there's no uh in arrows going to it
so that would affect the structure of
this
okay and then we can quickly code that
up
um so b0 is the context in state which
as we said is just going to be
stationarity
and then the choice given state is it's
fully controllable and then we will
parameterize this all as a create B
function which will for now have this P
change thing so we can make the agent's
belief about the stationary of the
context
um different like if the context is
likely to change but for now by setting
it to zero it just means that they
believe the context is fixed for a given
uh trial or set of time points
and then finally very basic stuff this
is just how we establish the semantics
of the reward modality so the reward
modality is as we said the null the loss
and the reward and we can encode the C
Vector which is kind of like the reward
function
um the prior preferences or prior over
observations
directly in terms of the log relative
log probabilities so we can encode
punishment by having the prior
expectation about loss be much lower in
relative log in in Nats natural log
units much lower than the reward
observation within that modality and
then the other ones are just going to be
uniform distribution so you can leave
them empty
and this is just what allows them to
want to see reward as opposed to loss or
punishment
and uh yeah so just as I think we
discussed this last time
um Daphne had a question about that so
why do we encode things in relative log
probabilities rather than Shear
probabilities is just more analogous to
the reward construct from reinforcement
learning that's one benefit so and
they're unbounded you don't have to they
don't have to be bounded between zero
and one so if you just encode them that
way it becomes easier to kind of make
one thing x times more rewarding or
punish or aversive than another thing
and that directly relates to how kind of
reward is calculated in our expected
utility of the expected free energy is
because it's always kind of an expected
it's kind of like an entropy or a cross
entropy so it's always
um it's you its units are in in natural
log space
okay so yeah
um and then the D Vector again they can
have prior beliefs about which context
is better so that will also be a
collection of vectors one over the
context factor and one over the
um the initial state of where they are
they are which we can make it start but
it doesn't really matter because they
have precise observations
and then that's very easy to do in Prime
DP
we'll just create some functions that
parametrize how rewarding the reward
observation is and how punishing the
punishment observation is
and then we can plot those and you know
this could be 10
and then the reward is much more
is much better than the punishment or
the punishment could be very bad
in which case the punishment is much
much lower than both the null and the
the reward and here I'm showing the
belief the the prior directly in terms
of probabilities so when you convert the
log probabilities to probabilities these
things will become bounded between zero
and one
okay and then the D Vector assembly will
just create a quick function that
parameterizes how much they believe the
left is better is the left is better
context is true at the beginning of the
simulation and if you just set that to
0.5 it means they have flat unbiased
uninformed prior beliefs about the
context
um yes okay
all right so now I think we are good to
actually do this after all the build up
um so like 95 of the work is in encoding
the generative model and this is
something Carl will tell you as well SPM
like most of the work is not actually
running active inference maybe
computation wise it is but in terms of
the time and the intellectual energy
spent it all comes down to the
generative model that's where all the
information is the rest is just
optimization basically
um so we've written down our a b c's and
D's then we just basically plug them
into this agent API from PI mdp and then
we
create an environment class which could
be as something as uh ad hoc as I'm
getting a list of observations from some
like API that's talking to the internet
or like from a robot sensors or you can
actually write down an environment class
that generates uh observations like like
another agent for instance
um and then you plug the observations
from the environment into the in first
States function you do infer policies
and then you sample an action according
to the expected free energy stuff that
we talked about last time
Okay so
now we're actually going to do this so
we have our nice Nifty functions for
creating a b c and d we can just run
those with desired levels of P hint and
P reward
and then create our agent
and um this is something we discussed
last time but an important distinction
is the generative model versus the
generative process or the environment so
the things we're putting in a and b
right now and and C are just the agent's
beliefs about for instance the hint
accuracy or the payoff Matrix of reward
that can be arbitrarily different from
the actual structure of the environment
and we'll see how later we'll see how
you can adjust the agent can actually
learn the correct reward statistics
through process of learning so even if
they start out with the wrong generative
model they can adapt their generative
model online so that they um they match
the generative process better
okay and then we'll Define this quick
class the two Arm Bandit which will be
the generative process the real world
for our agent we're not going to step
through the code but um the link is
available so if anyone wants to look at
this this is basically just encoding the
rules of the game so when the agent is
in the left arm they'll get reward or
lost depending on
the P reward and P hint values and as we
said these values can be different than
the agent's beliefs about them which
will be in their a matrix
so this is the generative process the
actual reward and then the generative
model are
the parameters you give to the a
Constructor
and then we'll just have a function here
that runs the active inference Loop it
looks a little bit more complicated than
those three lines I showed on the slide
but that's just because I'm storing
things like the history of their choices
the history of their beliefs
um I'm having optional plotting of
beliefs things like that and plotting of
actions
but this function basically that the key
Things Are
you get an observation from the you
start with an observation which it will
be from the generative process you do
hidden State inference using that
observation to get your posterior over
hidden States
and this you can return if you want to
plot it but you don't have to and then
you'll do inference about policy so this
is optimization of a posterior over
policies which then gets translated into
a marginal posterior Over Control States
or actions that you sample from
and you sample from them if this next
line with sample action so the main
three lines of any active inference
process are inference
about States inference about policies
and then action selection which can be
either deterministic or stochastic
depending on your application and then
the rest is just basically code that
converts observations
from the generative process into like
the terms that the agent can understand
and vice versa
and then we have this helper function
that plots the history of choices and
beliefs in the true context over uh over
time
so yeah I just Waze through that quickly
because it's not very important but we
can if anyone has questions we can go
back and dissect that code a little more
um
so now all we have to do is to find the
oh yeah you have your hand up you'll ask
something uh yeah
um maybe
um maybe this is better better suited
for
um for the end but
um in Prime DP there's also modules that
are adjacent to the Asian class
uh so I was just wondering how you um
how we could make use of the different
modules in the action perception Loop
um because I haven't I haven't seen many
examples of uh
of using for instance the inference
module or the learning module and how
that would augment
the Run active information yeah that's a
great question um so I have another demo
that we can maybe do another time that's
uh building a hierarchical model in pi
mdp so building a two layer model it's a
visual foraging hierarchical model based
on a paper that we did back in 2018 2019
and um and there you you're in this
inner loop over time you're doing you're
making use of these sub-module functions
so say you wanted to do some special
kind of inference
that's not just the standard in first
States
you could actually say Okay I want to do
this particular weird thing that's
specific to this inference process and
you would just add lines here
um like I want to take a function from
the inference module and run like I
don't know a different kind of message
passing on it
um like we're on to MMP or something
inference dot or that there's an Algos
module too that has different message
passing algorithms and then you could
optimize your hidden State beliefs using
that message passing algorithm and then
set them uh equal to the the like
special thing you did just just with
that
oops
so yeah there's no examples here but
um I haven't done that here but it's
definitely something that can be done
um
or yeah there's another example I did
like simulating an active inference
equivalent of an Evidence accumulation
drift diffusion style task where the
policy selection was done in a
particular way where you're only using
certain components of the expected free
energy
and uh and yeah so so basically there's
other demos where you can like zoom in
and not use the agent class and use sub
modules but I haven't written
those in like a publicly accessible way
yet but I can the hierarchical one I can
just easily make public I just haven't
had time to put it on the docs yet but
yeah that's a good question because yeah
you're right most of the stuff right now
is just the highest level implementation
with the agent
um okay
and now uh that to just run the active
inference process we just I've made a
distinction between generative process
parameters like how accurate the hint is
how uh how the payoff structure is and
then generative model parameters which
are used when creating the a matrix so
the P hint end is the true hint accuracy
P reward end is the true payoff and then
just choose some time Horizon and run
the active inference loop with that time
Horizon
and then plot the history of beliefs
okay so here's an example
um the top plot shows the agent's
Behavior so white squares indicate what
it was doing
at any given time so time is on the
x-axis so you can see it start in the
start State then it gathered information
at the hint
and the reason this wasn't immediate is
because it's beliefs about accuracy were
only 0.7 so it needs to actually do some
evidence accumulation before it's sure
what the state is then it played right
but as soon as it played right because
that's what the hint was telling it as
soon as it played right it probably had
a a loss
um
a loss observation which then messed up
its inference and made it go back to the
hint to accumulate evidence again before
being okay the hint is really suggesting
that I should go right so then it goes
back revisits the right arm and then
over time you see here the Red Dot is
the actual true context and the
grayscale indicates the agent's beliefs
about the hidden state
so here
um the hidden State beliefs are now
converging to
believing that the right arm is better
and I know I said at the beginning that
all probability would be darker means
higher probability but it's actually the
opposite here so sorry that's confusing
um so yeah right better is higher
probability
and their beliefs get more and more
confident as they play so this is you
know this this is the exact same thing
you'll see with the teammates right they
first
forage for information that's driven by
this epistemic value component of the
expected free energy as their posterior
over hidden States becomes more precise
epistemic value goes down and then
um the expected utility component goes
up which is bolstered by the fact that
they now have confident beliefs about
the context and then that drives them to
forge information
um and then so like that kind of
exercise that I would have people do if
this was like in a classroom context is
start messing with
the Bandit probabilities and also mess
with the agent's sensitivity to
punishment so up here we made them have
plus two relative Nets in their reward
function and minus four for punishment
but if you made this even lower let's
say it made it negative six
what would happen
so now because they're more risk-averse
the um the risk of getting a loss
observation if I was to play immediately
becomes higher so now the agent
basically requires more confidence
before it's willing to actually play the
left arm because the risk of getting it
wrong and getting a loss is too great
because their reward function is now
shaped more risk adversely
and then if I like decrease this even
more
down to negative eight you can see that
they never even go for play
because even once they're very certain
that the left arm is better it's still
too risky
given their beliefs about the payoff
structure
because there are beliefs about the
payoff structure are such that they
believe that there's still a 20 chance
that they'll get lost but if we change
this and said what if their P reward was
1.0
or say 0.99
then they're willing even despite the
great risk of being punished
because the the expected reward given
you know the context is high enough
they will still end up
um risking it and they acquire the hint
for some time and then they start
risking it
but they're the observations will
because peer reward is so high their
their beliefs about the payoff structure
their beliefs will kind of oscillate as
the observations actually change because
the true observations are generated much
more stochastically because this is the
peer reward of the Bandit
so you'll you can mess around with this
and and like I would encourage if anyone
listening now or afterwards
um wants to mess with these parameters I
would encourage you to just go crazy and
mess with parameters and see what
different kinds of behaviors you can get
um yeah
okay so that pretty much wraps up the
main brunt of the tutorial
and let's pause there for questions
because I have additional material about
learning parameters that we discussed
last time would be good to
to
um get into because that's something
that's really under documented right now
with primevp so we can move into that
but I think we should first break for
some questions
awesome thank you Jacob if you want to
ask or Carl otherwise I'm happy to hear
about learning
cool
let's do learning and then we'll have
any closing questions at the end
perfect
okay
I'll have some quick slides so
learning under active inferences cast as
updating beliefs about the generative
model parameters itself so inference is
one thing inference is saying given my
generative model so my beliefs about the
the way the world Works what is the best
explanation in the sense of posterior
over hidden States and policies
that explains my actual data and you get
that by minimizing variational free
energy learning is much um becomes much
more complex but also more interesting
in the sense that if the agent's
generated model itself is wrong they can
change the generative model to also
optimize variational free energy so
learning and inference can kind of
cooperate to or sometimes interfere with
each other as we'll see to to minimize
variational free energy so the way we
have to start by doing this is now
treating the parameters themselves so
the parameters of the a array which are
categorical likelihood parameters B
array d-array C array those themselves
now become random variables over which
we can have priors and of course
variational posteriors
um so we can go back to our original a
or Palm DP representation so now what we
see is in this third column next to a b
c and d we have parameters that are
priors over
the categorical
um parameters of the a b c and d so a
natural
um prior for these sorts of categorical
variables is called the dear Schley
distribution which is a um it's
basically a conjugate prior for a
categorical likelihood distribution
that's why it's very nice and also the
values of its parameters have a very
nice intuitive
um feeling and interpretability to them
so now the agents will have priors which
are updated by this P of Phi at the top
um and Phi is just a collection of all
these dirichlet hyper parameters they're
also called or prior parameters and
these are parameters or priors over
random variables that themselves are the
likelihood distributions and priors of
the generative model
so we're just going to do a few
instances of learning today I don't know
if we'll have time to do b or d learning
we'll start with a matrix learning but
um
but the principle applies the same so
here's an example of a deer slate prior
distribution over some categorical
parameters so let's say our a matrix or
a array let's just say it's a matrix so
now the random variable itself are the
entries of the a matrix
a prior of over those entries is
something called a deer slay
distribution which is just a vector of
real positive real numbers and here
we've reshaped it so that it has the
shape of an area so let's say this array
represents like the payoff Matrix in our
Bandit task so the two columns are two
possible hidden states are context one
context two and then the two
observations are punishment and reward
so if this is our prior which is
measured by these deer slay
um parameters
the likelihood distribution that they
parametrize also you can express this as
the expected value of the dershland
distribution is a categorical with these
values so what you can see is that the
deer Chalet
um counts like the the num the kind of
scalar magnitude of the deer slate
parameters kind of represent a prior
confidence about the probability of
um of the different contingencies
encoded in the a matrix so I made these
these very simple
um here like the the gear slave priors
are not nine counts for seeing
punishment given context and one count
for seeing reward given context one but
you can change those to very very high
numbers so for instance if that 9 on the
left was changed to a ten thousand then
on the right the probabilities would
become like 0.9999 to
.0001 so the scale of the deer slay also
known as pseudo count parameters encode
something like a
belief about how many times that
particular Coincidence of observation in
Hidden state has been observed which you
can also think of as like a prior
confidence about that contingency
um and the expectation to create your a
matrix via this uh going from a deer
slate to an a array is very simple
because you just take each deer slate
count and divide it by the column wise
sum which is this a naught variable on
the lower right so it's just that
particular value of the the a array and
divided by the sum of the counts
um so that's how you go from a deer site
prior over a categorical likelihood
distribution through the expectation
um and then inference and I'm not going
to get into like the variational
posterior but it's very simple so when
you're doing learning and you're trying
to actually update these deer parameters
as a function of observations what
essentially you have is a new posterior
that's not now not over hidden states of
the world but you have a variational
posterior over the parameters the
categorical or rather a variational
posterior over the deer Schley
distribution the deer distribution that
parameterizes your a matrix so that's
what's representing the lower right so
let's assume that our beliefs about the
deer shlay parameters were as it is now
so your beliefs about the a matrix
and then we get an observation
and let's say that we saw the
observation of punishment
and that can be represented by this one
hot vector
now we want to update our beliefs about
uh the a matrix given the observation
but what to do that what you also need
is a hidden state or a belief about
hidden States and let's say that the
agent uh was very confident that the
hidden state was context one
what ends up happening to the resulting
posterior over the a matrix
is a very simple associative
quasi-associative learning rule where
the update to the a the deer slay
represented by this um bold a Sub-Q
becomes the prior over the deer slight
parameters plus the outer product
between the observation vector and the
hidden State belief Vector so this is
kind of like a form of coincidence
detection where you just see what parts
of the Hidden States line up with what
parts of the observations and you
increment your beliefs about the a
matrix accordingly so in this case if I
really believe the context was one and I
saw a punishment then my belief about
that particular contingency
seeing punishment under context one
would just be incremented by a plus one
and that's what this outer product at
the lower right calculates it computes a
matrix that is the increment to your
beliefs about the a matrix so in this
case The Matrix would be have one in the
upper left and then zeros in the other
three entries and you use that to kind
of increment your your a matrix
technically you're incrementing a deer
Chalet kind of conjugate prior over your
a matrix but it's a very a variational
it's really a variational dirichlet
posterior
but you can imagine if your hidden
states are also contaminated with
uncertainty so say you had uh 50 your 50
50 whether it was context one or context
two then similarly with this a matrix
update the update would then be spread
over the two
um possible contingencies so if you saw
an observation but you weren't sure what
the hidden state was then both that the
just the overall probability of seeing
punishment under your generative model
would go up because you would increment
that entire row of the a matrix within
this case 0.5
so that's just an important thing to
note is that uncertainty in your own
hidden State beliefs will bleed into the
updates to the dirichlet parameters
and oftentimes alongside uh I mean it
optimally alongside a matrix learning or
parameter learning you're also going to
be augmenting your expected free energy
because your generative model is now
different so you have these new priors
and posteriors with a so-called
parameter Information Gain term or a
novelty term so while you're pursuing
learning it also makes sense to choose
your policies such that you'll maximize
um a kind of the information you get
based on the consequences of your
policies about the parameters of the
generative model so this this expected
KL Divergence exactly quantifies how
much a given policy will lead to a a
good Bayesian update of your parameter
beliefs so intuitively this quantity
might be um
described as how much do I expect the
consequences of my actions will update
my beliefs about parameters so
consequences of actions is represented
by that Q of O given Pi the thing that
the uh KL Divergence is taking taken
under expectation of
and then the actual KL Divergence is
saying how much surprise will I get
given these observations
um relative to my current beliefs about
the the parameters of the generative
model so this is what's called the
literature of the novelty term
and it's very easy to experimentally
turn off or on this novelty term
using simple Flags in in the agent class
and this goes for the other components
of the variation or the expected free
energy as well you can kind of turn on
flags that say do I want to use this
novelty or parameter information game do
I want to use the state info gain which
is the same as the epistemic value or
the Bayesian surprise and then do I want
to use the utility so for the learning
simulations it makes sense if you're
doing learning to have to make sure that
this parameter is turned on
um yeah okay so that's that's the kind
of um slides on on learning and now we
can actually get into implementing this
in primevp
um so
we first will create an a matrix and
we'll let the agent have very slight
positive beliefs about the reward
contingencies
and I'll explain later why this helps it
helps with learning if they don't have
total ignorance about the reward
probabilities but they have some bias in
some direction it doesn't actually have
to be 0.51 it could be the other way
um and then there's utility functions
that allow you to create dearishly
variables that have the same shape as
some base a array
so here we this pa
um
variable is basically the prior that
bold a sub P variable that represents
the agent's dirichlet prior over the a
matrix so this is now a new variable
that we're going to pass in to the
um to the agent Constructor so if our a
matrix is like
let's look at the
um you know the
reward contingency
reward modality so that's A1 so this is
the agent's current beliefs about the
the payoff structure right so under
choose left and choose right those are
the two contingencies given the two
hidden States PA will have the same
structure
except that it'll have
those contingencies encoded in terms of
dear slay pseudo counts so if I made
them
made this pseudo count scale 10.
then they are very con or quasi like
relatively confident
that the payoff probabilities look like
this
but again these are not probabilities
they're deer slay parameters that
parameterize a um categorical likelihood
so you can use the normalized
distribution function to actually then
visualize the dirichlet distribution in
terms of actual categorical parameters
which so taking the expectation I.E the
normalization of the deer slate prior
will give you exactly this
so if I say are these two things the
same they should be the same
okay maybe down to numerical differences
they're not but
yeah
um okay so yeah that's how you
parameterize that so we'll create a
this is an important Point that's also
used in SPM often we want certain
contingencies to be unavailable to
learning so we assume these are
contingency that are baked into the
agent's beliefs about the world and
that's not adaptable so one way and this
is just borrowed from the SPM way of
doing it to encode that is to bake in a
kind of um
really precise confidence or very high
confidence that certain contingencies
are the case and you can just do that by
adjusting the scale parameter for
particular indices so for instance by
doing this
I'm just telling the agent that it it
essentially doesn't learn the
contingencies related to the null
modality
um
so for instance if
if you're in the uh start state it
believes with really high confidence
that you'll always get the null
observation and we just operationalize
that by creating very very high pseudo
count or dear slay priors over that
particular slice of the a matrix
um so that's an important point to to do
and then we'll just write all this stuff
so this prior account about the null
observations and then the scale that
determines their General confidence
outside of this this um null thing we'll
write that all into a function so that
we can then parameterize our PA
and then we now write a new active
inference with learning Loop where
instead of just uh storing the history
of choices and beliefs we also store the
history of their beliefs about the
dirichlet parameters
um and an important thing that you can
also do in primevp which is nice is you
can say
I only want to learn particular
modalities so when you're creating the
agent class there's a bunch of arguments
you can pass in but one of them is I
only want to be learning the reward
payoff modality right now
and this can change you could have them
learn the the hint accuracy as well but
by passing in a list of which of the
modality indices that you want them to
learn you turn off learning on all the
other modalities which normally in SPM
more or what we used to have to do in pi
mdp is you just have to turn up those
deer pseudo counts super high on all the
modalities that you don't want to learn
but um if there are other modalities
that you don't want to learn now you
just you can just pass in this list of
modalities that you want to learn and
it'll only focus learning onto that
so now I'm setting up an agent
as these particular beliefs
about the world via a and now has a
prior that it's going to update through
doing variational inference or learning
and then so we'll create the generative
model here including this new prior over
a and then we'll run the active
inference loop with learning which
involves creating an agent that can only
do learning on the payoff structure
modality so we want the agent to now
learn
which arm is best basically because it
doesn't know the payoffs and then also
to use parameter Information Gain to
motivate its decision
and there's another thing I forgot to
mention which is the learning rate which
is how much they increment their beliefs
about the
posterior
or about the a matrix using this update
row so there's something I didn't
mention there's often a learning rate
that's that's added here that basically
scales how big this update is
so that can be you know you can
experiment it depends on the on the
application how what what the scale of
that is going to be but the default is
one
okay
so in this in this example the agent
gets the hint for one time step
he's got the standard like negative four
punishment
and then it goes straight to the right
because it believes the
um the hint is accurate so it gets a
reward is right then it goes and starts
playing the right arm
and uh you see it's posterior beliefs
instantly go to right
and now so since what we've also spit
out of this active infant soup is the
beliefs about the
um a matrix in this QA hist posterior
over a history we can plot its beliefs
about the a
um the a matrix probability over the
contingency of seeing reward given that
I was in the right arm
and what you see is that even though
they start with basically 50 50 beliefs
as they gather observations
their beliefs about that posterior
probability over that particular entry
of the a matrix get bigger and bigger
an interesting consequence of this is
their beliefs about the left arm
contingencies don't change because they
don't ever experience that that um state
of the world
so that's like an interesting um what
you might call in uh in machine learning
like a
it's not really a bad bootstrap but it's
the idea of
um like selective sampling so you only
learn those contingencies
that are selective to the part of the
world that you're sampling so I don't
the agent doesn't know what that other
slice of the a matrix looks like because
it's never experienced what it's like to
be in the left is better context
and and playing the left arm so it has
no it's posterior beliefs about that
part of the a matrix remain the same but
you can see that over time its beliefs
start to converge to point a which is
what we set in the uh in the generative
model
this is just basic statistical learning
right it's just getting reward
observations over time and as it gets a
sequence of reward and Punishment
through this very associative basic
mechanism is just incrementing its dear
slay beliefs and what I'm showing is the
normalized IED expectation of those
beliefs over time so you get something
that's 0.8 but the actual dirichlet
parameters themselves will be growing
um like linearly in time effectively
depending on the observations they get
um yeah so that is just a basic learning
and then there's another thing you can
do which is
take advantage of this change
probability so now we allow the context
to change and this is one way to get
them to actually be able to explore and
learn more about both reward
probabilities in the landscape is allow
them to have
not only to make the environment change
but they also entertain
beliefs in their in their uh B Matrix
that the the environment can change so
you could use this to do B Matrix
learning as well by defining like a PB
variable but here we're just going to
have a matrix learning as we were doing
before I've changed a little bit the
parameters to make things like a little
more stable
um because sometimes you get weird
Behavior I mean that's something we can
play around with too so now they allow
the the environment itself can change
and they also in their B Matrix they
think the environment can change
and then I'll plot
uh the history of beliefs and choices so
now
they instantly go for
um playing the arms they kind of risk it
they don't the parameter Information
Gain actually outweighs the epistemic or
state information game they start
playing they gather observations but
they're not very confident about what
the state of the world is because they
only are getting information about the
hidden state from the actual sequence of
rewards and losses
and then eventually they go to the hint
because probably the utility becomes low
because they don't know what the reward
probabilities are and they're building
their own beliefs then they get the hint
then the hint is accurate so they have
very precise beliefs about the hidden
state of the world
and then the the world actually switches
so you see the Red Dot is the actual
switching statistics of the Bandit and
now they've kind of explored wolf band
at Arms while also updating their
beliefs about the
the bandits
and you see that their beliefs about
their left arm are kind of bad because
they they it seems like they probably
mostly gotten negative data while
they're in the left arm and they didn't
explore it very much
um and and yeah or no I guess at the end
they're exploring it quite a bit but
their their beliefs about it go down
because they have I guess a bad
experience with it
um yeah that's a left arm that's the
right arm but you can like keep trying
this and mess around with different
parameters and you'll get different
sorts of
uh beliefs
okay so here in this example there's
some switching going on the posters
aren't tracking very well until they
actually visit the hint and then their
posters start getting much more
um much more precise and then at that
point they can start making more precise
beliefs in this case
they ended up kind of doing poorly on
learning on both of them because the
true
the word probabilities are PA yeah
um but so everything I've talked about
so far is an example where learning can
often lead to sub-optimal outcomes
because it's done in an online fashion
so this is an interesting Point of
Departure between SPM and pine DP but I
mean you can do all the same things in
SPM that you can do in pi VP so here
what I'm doing is I'm updating the a
matrix every time I get an observation
so they do hidden State inference they
select policies
they select actions and then given the
last observation and the last hidden
State belief they do one step of
parameter inference and they use the
next a matrix that's what's handled in
this update a function of of the agent
class they update their beliefs about
the a matrix and they use that for
inference at the next time step
another way you could do this is you
could do an entire trial
and then update your a matrix at the
very end of all the time steps of action
selection and observation sampling and
then use that a matrix for another trial
so this is kind of the difference
between
um like a more em uh like a separation
of time scales em or expectation
maximization approach where given a set
of observations then I update my model
and then I go back and I do more trials
without updating my model but using the
same fixed one and then you can kind of
do that in epochs and that's typically
how it's done in SPM because you only do
parameter learning basically this part
outside this time Loop so you do it like
down here but then what you do is you
run multiple trials
and the the nice thing about that is it
kind of makes the a matrix updates less
um likely to in the moment bias your
action selection so for a given set of
time steps you're you're locked into
what your a matrix beliefs are and you
don't do the update until a set of time
steps has elapsed
and uh yeah so for the purposes of this
tutorial I just did this online learning
thing but as you can see that can lead
to actually weirdly sub-optimal Behavior
where they don't learn the true reward
statistics very well
and it depends on a bunch of things too
like the learning rate and you know
there's a I haven't explored this demo
as much as I would like but there's a
lot of interesting kind of side effects
like here they're actually learning very
weird statistics about the the Bandit
landscape like they start kind of
learning it well but then as their
observations keep going they don't they
don't actually learn very well here they
just avoid playing because they have a
bad early experience so this is an
example of like a bad bootstrap and then
they go and just play the hint because
they're too scared of anything else even
though they're hidden State inference is
perfect
because the hint perfectly tracks the
hidden state
so yeah there's it's just um this is
just a kind of meant to be an example of
what you can do with learning
um but there's there's going to be
examples where learning actually causes
sub-optimal Behavior but in an
interesting way
so here's an example where they actually
kind of are learning the correct reward
statistics things are starting to
converge to point eight for both Bandit
arms
but um but it's very stochastic as you
can see and I also chose action
selection to be stochastic
with deterministic I wonder what you
would get
um yeah yeah they're just Arc maxing the
expected free energy or Arc meaning so
hint is always the most
safest option given their history of uh
observations
if I can make one remark on that kind of
diversity behaviors that we're seeing
pi mdp and active inference are
providing us a space and a approach to
composable generative model construction
that we can then sift through and to
co-evolve with to find different
strategies and behaviors so active
inference or even any specified
generative model it's not an answer or a
solution for example to the explore
exploit dilemma we see this like
empirically right now active inference
is not in general resolving explore
exploit anygm in general is not
resolving explore exploit any
parameterization is not resolving
explore exploit even for one environment
it just is equivalent to saying like
well we have a linear model of
healthcare data so we've resolved the
health care issue and
um this really this really shows the
space that we build in and what remains
to be built
is so open
yeah absolutely yeah I mean because
optimality is not really a function of
what the gender model is or what the
algorithm is what's it's more guaranteed
to be optimal based on how analogous the
generative model and the generative
process are so if the gendered model is
a perfect model of the generative
process then doing Bayesian infants
inference with respect to that
generative model that is optimal for
like everything
but um but uh how you learn the
generative model that's what we're
seeing here if you learn the generative
model in online fashion it's not
guaranteed to learn the right to
generative model in many cases it learns
the wrong one
and this is something that a lot of
people in active inference world have
explored for instance nor Sajid who's
also a student of Carl's has explored a
lot the the limitations and the the
boundaries of parameter learning and
things like preference learning like
what if you were learning the C Vector
itself how can that be learned online in
an Adaptive way
um yeah and also Alec chance has that
paper action oriented models where
they're learning the B Matrix and in
that thing they're showing how the agent
learns kind of sub-optimal strategies
depending on its exploration of
parameter space
um but that also actually is kind of a a
one of the
benefits of active inference that paper
shows because it shows if you have an
agent that does have epistemic value the
model it learns of the world is like
better than agents that don't have
epistemic value but again that the
models are always action oriented
they're always based on what parts of
the full State space is the agent driven
to sample
awesome Jacob any closing comments and
then all the closing comment and then
Connor with the last word
yeah well thank you very much for the
great
um overview what particularly uh was
inter um I I found particular
particularly interesting was
um both how you touched on how it could
be modified uh with the action
perception look could be modified with
the other other modules even though uh
as you mentioned there would be more
opportunities to go deeper in that but
also on the on learning
um the
the duration parameters and I would be
interested to
um see how that uh also influences
planning uh like
if you would up if you would do like um
kind of pseudo update of your duration
parameters when you're calculating your
expected free energy as in what would I
uh I'm calculating my expected free
energy
whilst also taking into account that my
B would change on each in on each step
and uh how that how that changes like
the optimality of
the temporal depth that we do planning
with I think it's super super
interesting and really looking forward
to hopefully uh another model stream
yeah that's a um
okay is it okay if I quickly respond
yeah please please
um yeah that that's a very interesting
point that you just made about
um these this fictive or imagined update
whereas that I had a yeah this slide so
that term that novelty term in theory
that does capture exactly what you're
saying yakub is that this thing says how
would my dear straight parameters update
if I was to take this policy pie and
then I use that term to actually choose
where to explore next so if I turn on
the parameter information game term in
the agent class they'll much more
quickly skip that skip the hint and go
directly to sampling the bandits because
they're driven by novelty oh I want to
know what the reward probabilities are
so I'm going to go explore however when
it doesn't do and what I think you're
intimating with your comment is that
if I did like multi-step planning
two time steps in the future will I be
able to do my planning given how I think
I updated my parameters at the first
time step so that's what the equivalent
of sophisticated inference sophisticated
inference is saying how would I plan at
time step three given how I think my
beliefs would update up to time step two
and that's done right now for hidden
States but I haven't seen that done for
parameters and I think there's someone
like a student of Ryan Smith's uh is
working on that now
um is like this propagation of
counterfactual beliefs about how my
parameter beliefs would change in the
future
um and that's like that's like a really
cutting edge I think active inference
it's like not only novelty but how would
my like prospective sophistication about
how your own parameter beliefs will have
evolved by time Point T and then using
that to do planning for time Point t
plus one
um that's like a really sophisticated
stuff I think getting just even Bare
Bones sophisticated inference with
hidden State counterfactual stuff in in
Pine BP that would be a huge
accomplishment too and then of course
incorporating it to be more
um more uh with the parameter
sophistication as well and then another
quick thing is I can quickly show you
um an example of one of those other
oopsie
just while you're finding it the live
that that last discussion on
uh sophisticated planning
it's something that at the semantic
level we engage with every day what
courses should I take this quarter
so that I can learn what I don't know
today so that next quarter I'll be able
to make a better plan for which classes
to take so that in three years when I
graduate
but it's already phrased at the semantic
granularity that these models are
rapidly converging towards and they're
not converging towards it by scaling is
all you need they're converging towards
it with a factorized actually semantic
approach which is very exciting
yeah that's a great analogy it's like by
the if you were a naive active inference
agent without sophistication you would
never plan with like a 10 time step
planning Horizon you never plan to take
or let's say a three semester planes
Rising you never plan to take
multivariate calculus
in your third semester because you will
you would not have anticipated by the
second semester I now have enough linear
algebra to take I know that by the time
I finish the second semester I will now
know linear algebra so I'll be well
suited to take multivariable calculus
whereas what we as humans do is we do
have that parameter sophistication I can
plan as a freshman as a first year to
take in my third or fourth semester some
high Advanced physics because I know by
that time I will have the requisite
multi-variable calculus or whatever so
that's a that's a really nice analogy
that I never
I think that's a good uh a good example
welcome to active View
yeah exactly
um so here uh
I just wanted to show you Jacob um
here's an example of a hierarchy
hierarchical active inference demo I can
share this too it's another collab
notebook where we're exactly doing we're
composing to palmdps so there's like a
high level Palm DP
and then there's a low level Palm DP and
for example when you're doing a step of
updating the empirical priors at the
high level before you pass them down to
be empirical priors at the low level we
use the control module for example to do
get expected States or use the high
level beliefs the high level B Matrix
and then the high level chosen action to
propagate forward the next posterior
beliefs at the high level and then those
things themselves parameterize a low
level empirical prior for this faster
Palm DP that's going on at the low level
so this is an example where you're
composing like agent class calls like
this but you're composing them with
functions that are built from sub
modules and adjacent modules of prime DP
um so that's an example of the thing you
were talking about but yeah that's very
brief like we can get into that um later
on
in a different stream or something like
that yeah
awesome Yes uh dot three whenever the
time is right I'll I'll just give two
closing areas
again really
appreciate coming back on and sharing
this development in progress already
it feels more powerful and documented
than when we were in the dot one just a
few
weeks or months ago
I think two areas that are going to be
really exciting to discuss and see how
they're implemented and also the
plurality of ways that they're
implemented
the first area is structured learning on
cognitive models from the outside so as
a ethologist as a behavioral researcher
how do we do structure learning on
cognitive models
four systems that we actually know about
their cognitive architecture or not but
also the view from the inside in terms
of structured learning and metacognition
like how should I change the
dimensionality of my B Matrix or should
I turn on that flag to engage in this
kind of sophisticated inference so
structure learning on cognitive models
view from the outside View From the
Inside is one exciting area and the
second more experimental area is
statistical power analysis pre and
post-hoc statistical power analysis
along the lines of the design Matrix in
SPM
so that you put 15 time steps and 0.8.2
and punishment is for
and then you could sweep across
parameters and learn about how well it
did but if there was certain interfaces
analytical or numerical approaches to be
like yes with 25 time steps
we have this much of an expectation of
convergence or this differential in
rewards should be resolvable by an
Adaptive agent over this long
and just understand how long should
these experiments be because there are
such interesting results with One-Shot
learning and with being able to generate
someone's voice from just 10 seconds of
them talking or make a video of somebody
as a deep fake with just a still image
and so it seems like it's possible to
learn a lot from a little
and if we can learn a lot from a little
and have a semantic cognitive model
that would be quite great
absolutely yeah like
it's almost like hyper parameter
optimization on the landscape of active
inference models like how do I choose
the parameters of an active inference
model in a smart way
um yeah there's several methods for
doing that like yeah that we could uh
definitely explore
yeah data efficiency is the main main
thing like you said like making it so
you don't have to train it on a trillion
images like with a deep neural network
perfect and Dot 007.2 and whenever you
want to join you in any colleagues are
are always welcome to share the next
spiral in pi mdp development
awesome thank you so much again for
letting me come on and listening I hope
it was helpful
um yeah and I'm glad that it's recorded
it's really an amazing resource that you
guys are developing here so thanks again
thank you till next time bye
[Music]